has this ever happened to you
we've all been there what is mark
wahlberg workout right now she's trying
to rip off these stickers the paper rips
oh
nope
the incomplete answers
what does reggie wants the residue too
what is emily blunt oh for god's sake
herpes
we fixed it introducing a scientific and
revolutionary product wired auto
complete glue the perfect peel every
time how does it work
we tasked a chemist with creating a
unique formula
one and a half cups of water a half a
cup of cornstarch a quarter cup of corn
syrup and then two teaspoons of white
vinegar you're going to stir it all
together nice and slowly over medium-low
heat you are going to watch it change
right in front of your eyes and when you
see that change happen your glue is
ready
now we're giving you a glue that only
sticks when you need it
your glue stick typically contains one
main molecule and it's called polyvinyl
acetate and this is a beautiful molecule
that contains a polar side and a
non-polar side so the non-polar part of
the glue is going to interact with any
non-polar parts of whatever it is you're
trying to stick on to stick together
whereas the polar side of the glue is
going to interact whatever side of the
polar piece it is that you're trying to
stick together so polar goes with polar
non-polar goes with nonpolar and the
combination of which gives us adhesive
and cohesive properties the cohesion and
adhesion create the stick
so cohesive meaning it likes to stick
with itself it's not going to rip in
half and adhesive meaning it wants to
stick to whatever it else it is sticking
to so it sticks to itself and to what
else it's sticking to that's perfect
is owen wilson
is tim heidecker really glued him on
tight your regular store-bought glue
just can't do what our wire tested an
approved glue can ding ding ding
thanks
[Music]
wired blue is guaranteed to be the
perfect glue
every time
call now to secure your wired auto
complete glue today wired automatically
with pixel products created by wired for
this video it's not a real product it's
not available for purchase the step
describe this video or representative
how all the works that are specific blue
or any other frameworks